hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today is gonna be a little bit
different and of course because I'm such
an original youtuber of course I would
do this idea we're not serious though
just in case you don't know what's going
on there's this glitch with the legacy
bundle pack in the store currently in
for honor or if you basically hop into a
duel match and back out really quickly
it's it's supposed to be I believe a
duel AI mode if you hop in and hop out
real quickly then you will basically
glitch out the thing to where it'll have
your character do other characters
emotes and executions like shinobi doing
shougo Keys execution vice versa all
that type of stuff and it creates this
really weird and wacky type looking
effect where your weapons aren't really
supposed to be doing what they're doing
of course because you're not the
specific character all the ornaments are
misaligned everything's going absolutely
batshit crazy and it's really funny to
look at especially for your favorite
character but I have to give credit
where credit is due though regardless
shout out to Jake or Ella and splice
their channels will be in the
description below they should be doing
this type of thing with their type of
favorite characters as well be the guys
like the view if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I cover the leaks the
information the patch notes the hero
updates the balance changes of for honor
as well as doing some wacky dumb massive
videos like this and with that guys hope
every yesterday and enjoy the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you